college athletes can now make money off
their name image and likeness the world
of college sports is changing
dramatically and many of those
university officials were in las vegas
for the annual convention that just
wrapped up and as logan reaver tells us
tonight one of the big topics has to do
with name image and likeness
on friday it'll be a year since the name
image in likeness role was placed into
effect in college sports at first there
was a hesitancy from athletic directors
all over the country and those here at
nacta since that time dudes have signed
on from everything from luxury cars to
just getting a couple more chicken
tenders from their favorite spots and
now it's only getting even bigger
you know people are referring it to the
wild wild west but you know we think we
have a really good product former notre
dame quarterback brandon wimbush now
helps current players get deals done
with his app name mogul fourth rushing
touchdown to blow this one open provide
value for
you know the other 99 percent of
athletes who are not the trevor
lawrence's or the zion williamson's
of the world which is where nil plays in
when it comes to unlv
sure the bucks aren't in the millions
but it drastically can change the life
of a rebel according to on three dot com
their market value system has junior
quarterback harrison bailey worth 72
thousand dollars and three star commit
keyshawn hall with a market value of 36
000 without even playing a game yet
and it might even help mid-majors like
them to have a chance to win i think
what it does more than anything else
that is it actually establishes more
parity in collegiate athletics because
now athletes are going to be able to
make money no matter where they're going
to put the nil in perspective right now
2023 quarterback jaden rashada just
signed for 9.5 million dollars to a
miami booster that is more than most nfl
quarterbacks including trevor lawrence
kyler murray and joe burra who was just
playing for a super bowl back in
february from mandalay bay logan river
live local now all right thank you very
much logan it's amazing what these
athletes can now make off their name
image and likeness it's a total game
changer and they're so like you were
saying there's so many more questions
involved with this i mean if can these
can you move from miami now if this guy
says over at another university i can
pay you more does he quit there and go
to the transfer portal and boom he's off
to another show you do check with logan
on that